one time am I when I was in kindergarten
my mom she's like no it's Matthew it's
matt got English okay okay got it matte
Babel Entertainment Tonight Canada so I
mean in this movie you play an outlaw
who goes against the societal norms of
what's expected of a Whiteman yep and
I'm wondering for you and how you've
navigated life and and you know this
industry have you ever felt like an
outlaw I'm much more comfortable feeling
like an underdog even we even when i'm
winning I I find a way to feel like I'm
an underdog because I just work better
from that place um i'm not i'm not an
affiliation guy and i personally have
never been an affiliation guy i've got
my personal affiliations and those are
mine but i'm not one to sign 10 year
contracts or anyway I like being a free
agent mm-hmm um so outlaw I don't know
I've always kind of done things my own
way I like to work with the system I
understand the people that let me play
in the sandbox that we call making
movies and I sort of appreciate it and I
like to work with people at the same
time I like to make my own decisions and
like to go back and have my life outside
of this industry mm-hmm what about
either pressures of playing a character
that exists in actuality I mean it's
additionally sure when you're playing a
character does not feature can be yeah
there can be I mean I've done
biographical Paul Rowles before where I
felt the burden on my shoulder I did not
feel a certain freedom but I learned
from that experience and I've gone and I
went about this when I'm found I got
empowered by this guy I felt a lot of
freedom with this guy while still being
acute and responsible to who he was at
this time but this guy had a great
identity so it was there I had plenty I
didn't have to use my imagination to
conjure up things to best to expose and
express who the man was it was there it
was clear who he was to me it was clear
how he thought it was clear how simple
his Constitution was if he saw wrong he
could not ignore it he had to make it
right if he saw an injustice he couldn't
ignore it and
damn the consequences about it by the
Bible and a barrel of a shotgun that's
the way he was moving along and it's
still at the same time the empathy for
Humanity that the guy had was very clear
and inspiring what about yourself Andrew
I mean this characterize you said very
passion and willing to fight for those
things you know as a father is there
anything in real life that you're that
that you feel that passionate about that
you would be willing to fight for well I
don't you Father no okay we'll see when
you have kids that automatically becomes
something that there's just a line in
the sand really have things that you
would put up with and things you
wouldn't you really understand
protecting yours in your own and your
family um you know the thing that
happens after fatherhood as you go
before your father you go hey I can
handle myself if I get in a pinch I can
get out of it I'll survive mmm then you
have people come into your life that you
got to take care of that needs you to
survive and need you to thrive um you
know for me right now my family and
myself you know who were mostly taken
care of I've got a foundation where we
deal with title 1 school kids that are a
lot of them come from single-parent
homes and stuff like that that we give
them a safe place to go after school and
to earn schools all over America that's
another passion of mine where I feel
like I'm giving a helping hand and then
other than that got a I got a whole not
just my family my whole family nobody i
don't know i can they're all taken care
of this element yeah we do we take care
of each other good stuff you're not you
haven't uh um start our way south africa
so know yet